[Musique]
france 2022 c'est notre rendez vous avec
l'élection présidentielle chaque lundi
avec vous h rennes verdien bonjour et ce
sera quotidien à partir du 13 mars -
joue rafael bonsoir à vous tous cette
semaine la bataille s'est nettement
intensifiée à l'extrême droite entre la
candidate du fn marine le pen et le
candidat du parti reconquête eric
zemmour attaques acerbes par médias
interposés durant la semaine et le week
end dernier c'était meeting
contre-meeting pendant ce temps à gauche
la victoire de christiane taubira la
primaire populaire n'a rien changé les
candidats poursuivent leur campagne dans
un climat délétère seul fabien roussel
garde le sourire le récap politique de
la semaine est signée florent rodo et
autriche les
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'une longue attente
qui prend fin quinze ans après les
communistes ont de nouveau un candidat à
la présidentielle premier grand meeting
pour fabien roussel à marseille semaine
de 32 heures smic à 1500 euros retraite
à 60 ans programme à gauche toute
le ruissellement macron c'est terminé
nous c'est le roux tellement convainc en
2022 pour irriguer l'économie réelle
lutter contre la vie chère
rendre le pouvoir d'achat aux français
sa victoire à la primaire populaire
devait lui servir de tremplin
christiane taubira face à côté de son
grand oral devant la fondation abbé
pierre si on augmente le rsa de 30% les
gens restent sous le seuil de pauvreté
quand même
oui mais on y ajoute on y ajoute voilà
on peut y ajouter
le l'apl d'une part et puis et puis je
je considère que
avant d'aller prendre l'air du côté
d'oléron
vous êtes courageuse
peut-être que j'ai l'habitude des
attaques d'une très grande violence donc
je ne fais pas d'illusions dans cette
campagne
lui tenait son premier meeting en
extérieur place de la république à lille
selphy en pagaille pour un yannick jadot
vert de rage
liberté égalité fraternité
pour nous ce sont les valeurs nous
sommes là
à gauche lui fait partie des mieux
placés en avril l'abstention pourrait
bien n'être record les déçus de la
politique
jean luc mélenchon veut les ramener aux
urnes
la résignation matin midi et soir
d'ailleurs vous avez perdu d'abord vous
êtes trop nombreux moi je rentre pas
là-dedans courage détermination de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique
match des meetings à l'extrême droite
samedi eric zemmour est à lille marine
le pen à reims deux salles une ambiance
on ne trouve plus beaucoup d' usine mais
on trouve beaucoup de mosquées on
cherche la france et on ne l'a su il ya
un lien évident entre l'explosion de
l'insécurité et ses vagues d'immigration
que nous subissons toujours pas candidat
mais déjà qualifiés pour le premier tour
emmanuel macron à ses 500 signatures au
cas où l'envi de se représenter lui
viennent à l'esprit en se rasant le
matin
voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
vivement la prochaine
et c'est déjà l'une des révélations en
tout cas de la campagne serait le
candidat du parti communiste fabien
roussel était en meeting c'était hier
dimanche à marseille devant 4000
personnes oui personnage jovial très à
l'aise en meeting comme dans ses
interviews il bénéficie d'un fort
capital sympathie une personnalité qui
détonne au sein de la gauche ce qui fait
évidemment grincer des dents on en parle
avec la chef du service politique de
france 24 ce soir rosine faivre bonsoir
roselyne fabien roussel veut donc
redonner à des couleurs au parti
communiste français oui c'est le
candidat qui fleure bon la france un
gain un gars bien chez nous et est bien
de chez nous aussi en tant que
journaliste puisque c'était un ancien
journaliste cameraman donc un candidat
qui veut retrouver quand on l'a vu sur
les images son slogan la france des
jours heureux alors on ne sait pas ce
que c'est que la france des jours
heureux pour lui est ce que c'est
lorsque le parti communiste vient
faisait un bon score ou était au
gouvernement avec françois mitterrand ou
la fameuse gauche plurielle on ne sait
pas où les trente glorieuses en tout cas
pour avoir dit cet homme qu'il aimait le
bon vin la bonne viande et le bon
fromage bien on l'a traité de traduit de
fachos de viandards de chauvin pour en
tirer la conclusion je vous le donne en
mille qu'il était un homme de droite et
franchement dire qu'un communiste et de
droite s'est inventé un drôle de concept
vous l'avouerez donc certains ont fait
monter la sauce en disant effectivement
c'est l'homme de droit qui plaît à la
droite ce qui n'a pas plu évidemment
place du colonel fabien et bien cette
petite polémique en fait de la viande du
fromage etc eh ben ça lui ça la fait
monter ses on parle du communiste comme
étant effectivement une sorte de
révélation de la campagne est basse et
lui a fait un peu son récit et pas
besoin d'aller payer des communicants
très cher il arrive il réussit
objectivement sa campagne il se trouve
un espace politique comme avait pu le
trouver marchais qui faisait des
blagounettes alors il y pas aussi
tonitruant et charismatique que georges
marchais mais il fait des blagues en
parlant non pas de la théorie du
ruissellement mais dur ou seulement à aa
donc voilà il fait il plaît il plaît
parce qu'il fait des blagues parce qu'il
est effectivement vous le disiez h
rennes il est jovial et puis aussi là où
on dit qu'il plaît à la droite c'est
qu'il n'évite pas les sujets sur la
sécurité l'insécurité ou sur le
l'islamisation dans certains quartiers
et puis il est pro nucléaires et des pro
industrie mais en gardant quand même les
mêmes fondamentaux parce que faut pas
non plus pousser mémé dans les orties
qu'avant dit le smic à 2000 euros
carrément quand certains ose à peine
dire 1500 euros lui allez hop 2000 euros
la semaine de 32 32 heures et puis lisf
on leur met oui mais on le triple
pourquoi pas donc fabien roussel est
clairement la révélation oui de cette
campagne mais on va pas s'emballer quand
même quand je dis révélation il est
quand même si on regarde les sondages il
est entre 3 et 4% un peu plus quand même
qu'anne hidalgo et il n'y avait pas eu
de candidat communiste depuis 2010 est
il y avait jean marie george buffet qui
était resté sur cette gamelle et
historique de 1,81 13% à la
présidentielle donc si ces scores se
confirme dans la réalité est bien il va
un peu rallumer la lumière au parti
communiste un communiste bon vivant
assez le portrait vous venez de nous
brosser rosie mais comme le dit l'adage
de bon vivant il ya prévoyant derrière
la bonhomie l homme de parti oui ce
qu'on pourrait dire l'apparatchik mais
quand même ce qui fait un peu tilt on va
dire c'est que en juillet 2000
21 fabien roussel donne une interview à
l'agencé chinoise xhinua lors d'un
déplacement à pékin parce qu'il vient
fêter avec les chinois les 100 ans du
parti communiste chinois est là dans un
étrange communiqué rendu public par le
journal français l'opinion eh bien ils
soulignent le bond remarquable de
l'économie chinoise sous l'égide du
régime communiste on a envie de sortir
les violons et les applaudissements il
vante les réussites de la recherche si
chinoise face à l'épidémie de
coronavirus et et que les chercheurs
chinois sont les meilleurs parce que ils
ont été les premiers à décrypter le
génome de ce virus est un peu plus loin
il dit et il salue l'action de la chine
contre le réchauffement climatique alors
qu'on sait que c'est quand même le plus
gros pollueurs du monde même si
effectivement il faut le reconnaître ils
font des efforts et puis rien sur les
droits de l'homme rien sur le sort de la
minorité ouïghoure donc dans l'entourage
de fabien roussel parce qu'il faut quand
même l'expliquer et bien lui l'entourage
du bas c'était un condensé peu équilibré
on n'a pas dit ça vraiment comme ça et
auparavant d'ailleurs fabien roussel
dit-on dans son entourage a pu
s'expliquer lors d'un séminaire à
l'ambassade de chine à paris sur et bien
les les droits de l'homme et qu'il
aurait dit ses désaccords avec la chine
bon on peut le croire ou pas en tout cas
ce communiqué très bizarre n'a pas du
tout retenu l'attention des français et
voilà fabien roussel fait une vraie
bonne campagne et oublier le communiqué
chinois merci beaucoup aux aînés on vous
retrouve dès demain dans une version
longue de votre émission mardi politique
vous recevez demain avec frédéric
rivière de rfi nicolas dupont aignan
seulement et on revient à présent h
rennes sur la guerre fratricide entre
marine le pen et eric zemmour les deux
représentants de l'extrême drogue et
sont donnés au coude à coude dans les
sondages oui même à égalité selon un
dernier sondage ipsos sopra steria avec
chacun 14% d'intentions de vote au
premier tour et problème pour marine le
pen les défections se multiplient au
sein du rsa on a largement parlé après
les eurodéputés gilbert collard et
jérôme rivière non deux conseillers
municipaux et régionaux leur emboîtent
le pas dans ce contexte marine le pen a
joué cette semaine une nouvelle carte
celle de l'émotion se montrant
volontiers très affecté alors quelle
réaction cette fois du côté des
militants du rnd portage à reims où
s'est tenue samedi la convention
présidentielle de marine le pen signé
clovis casali
[Musique]
elle mise sur la france d oublier pour
la porter au pouvoir
marine le pen doit occuper le terrain
car à l'extrême droite un autre candidat
marche sur ses plates bandes l'ancien
journaliste eric zemmour
la volonté d'eric zemmour je crois et
plus de parasiter la campagne de marine
le pen et du rassemblement national
plutôt d'affronter emmanuel macron plus
on s'approche du pouvoir plus évidemment
nous pouvons avoir des freins sur notre
route ça fait 40 ans qu'on les affronte
mais on les affronte parce que nous
sommes soutenus par une majorité
silencieuse de français plusieurs poids
lourds du parti ont quitté le rn avec
fracas et d'autres pourraient suivre
dans les semaines à venir marine le pen
a prévenu que ceux qui s'interrogent sur
leur avenir devrait partir dès à présent
et son chance de revenir sa nièce marion
maréchal elle reste très évasive sur qui
elle va soutenir ici à reims ce sont les
partisans les plus fidèles de marine le
pen qui sont présents et pas tendre à
l'égard de ce qu'ils appellent des
traîtres et des lâches
c'est une mesure imerys n'aime pas qu'on
parle d'eux donc ont eu leur mandat
grâce au rassemblement de la nationale
et grâce aux électeurs du rassemblement
national donc c'est peut-être une forme
de trahison zemmour proposons c'est tout
ce qu'ils proposent des petits chèques
pour qu'on rejoint que nos cadres nos
militants rejoignent reconquête la
stratégie de l'open leur plaît
la candidate apparaît plus modéré que
zemmour marine est beaucoup moins
catégorique elle est beaucoup plus
sociable a dit pat et ses allées pas
raciste comme on pourrait dire à la pas
un langage très agressif envers eux à
des simplement comme nous que s'ils sont
bien s'ils respectent le pays nos
coutumes et notre loi ils peuvent rester
il respecte pas il retourne chez eux
pour contrer zemmour et accéder au
second tour le pen joue la carte de la
proximité avec des électeurs qui la
suivent depuis des années
elle en est persuadée ses seuls
adversaires sont emmanuel macron
et l'abstentionnisme
[Applaudissements]
et on en vient à notre portrait des
lecteurs a comme chaque semaine
direction aujourd'hui les pyrénées
orientales oui pour parler d'un
électorat traditionnellement très
convoité par les hommes politiques et
les femmes politiques les chasseurs un
million de français détiennent
aujourd'hui un permis de chasse sujet
devenu très clivant nos reporters julie
d'une golf et florence vie minots ont
rencontré un défenseur de la chasse
traditionnelle ludovic se laisse
regarder
[Musique]
la chasse j'ai commencé mes parents je
les suivais un petit puis une fois qu'on
est tombé dedans peut plus s'en passer
mais on voudrait que ça perdure parce
que la chasse au petit gibier c'est une
belle chasse pas surtout dans notre
département
[Musique]
née dans une chasse raisonnée si on perd
ce matin on dit ou fait perdre on va
certes content vous mentir à lui même
c'est pas ce qu'on attend quoi ce qu'on
attend le plus c'est de voir le chien de
travail c'est vraiment ce qu'il ya de
plus beau allez
on n'est peut-être pas les premiers
écolos de france mais on est les
premiers observateurs
pour jean-pierre
comment nous reprocher qu'on prélève aux
côtés des bêtes et depuis combien de
temps que tu des bêtes nous perdre en
paroles tout le monde faisait ça pour se
nourrir nous c'est pareil on continue la
tradition
il ya une tendance qui est en train de
monter évidemment végétarien c'est un
effet de mode quoi ça peut pas durer
parce que derrière il n'y a pas de
réelle valeur la tranquille
quand ils te parle de de colo j te dise
de réintroduire l'ours le loup ça
pourrait se faire mais alors il faut
arrêter il faut arrêter urbanisation
comment voulez vous qu'on l'ait
réintroduisent si on fait des feux des
panneaux photovoltaïques si on n'arrête
pas le construire des maisons ils vont
vivre comment ils vont trouver la
nourriture
après l'effort le réconfort
je me rappelle quand j'étais gosse
c'était peut-être les belles années il y
avait il y avait du gibier c'était plus
convivial aussi maintenant on se
retrouve tous les deux ici c'est vrai il
était le club de rugby s'il n'y avait
pas ça
peut-être que personne se connaîtraient
anglais
si j'étais président j'ai instauré dans
l'éducation nationale l'étude de la
biodiversité française je resterai
chasse traditionnelle chasse à la glu et
la chasse de loi pour avoir suivi
régulier et permanent des espèces
migratrices
on termine comme chaque lundi avec notre
bonus l'art chiffre de la semaine oui un
petit clin d'oeil à l'interview de
valérie pécresse hier soir sur france 5
qui en a surpris plus d'un quand elle a
adressé un message à la russie de
vladimir poutine en version originale
écouter ya quelque chose kazakh gordon
moore aus comme on a road au château
louis jean yves miss tiësto y tenir mais
vos pieds à la tête vainio
craignent la boue rouge a smashé prix
voilà compétences en russe est allé un
peu maladroitement sur ce plateau
télévisé mais il est vrai qu elle
maîtrise très bien cette langue elle qui
a fréquenté les camps des jeunesses
communistes en urss à deux reprises
durant son adolescence mais beaucoup
d'hommes et femmes politiques français
raphaël ne sont pas aussi à l'escale
avec les langues étrangères petit
florilège tout de suite regardé
oui je hais ce
ninja au queen games et nos actrices you
will succeed in place
because we must aubeterre de réseau we
made you that because you are there and
hate forme d'api paul the world will
hayes act for you et allied world we
want succès
on est mort de m et c'est tout pour
cette semaine de campagne raphaël merci
beaucoup c'est la fin de 2022 l'heure du
choix vous pouvez nous retrouver
évidemment sur notre site internet
france 24 points comme sur les réseaux
sociaux et puis à noter a également
notre nouvelle page sur le site internet
toujours où sont regroupés à tous les
contenus de l'élection présidentielle
merci à fred on se retrouve évidemment
siens lundi prochain même heure avant le
passage prochain en quotidienne quand la
campagne va s'accélérer évidemment et
non se retrouve dans quatre minutes pour
un nouveau journal dans paris direct